brad keller who got his first big league
win against the indians two years ago
and has always pitched well against
cleveland he sure has you know he'll be
looking to do that again here tonight
and a breaking ball strikes out
hernandez
and a full count of three and two and
keller already has thrown 16 pitches
look at that ramirez didn't want to go
but he's got to keller with another
slider right-hander shane bieber on the
hill tonight he's been the best pitcher
in baseball here in 2020 20.
missed
and he strikes him out two down
got him jane bieber strikes out a pair
here in the first and we are scoreless
after one
oh man franco
whoa on the money to ryan o'hearn and
brad keller gets a one two three second
inning with the help of his defense
put a star on that one
that was beautiful he picked it out of
clean air
he picked that that ball was on him at
100 plus i'm not sure the exact exit
velo but it was hit hard that's a double
for sure
threw it by him and gordon strikes out
third k for shane bieber let's see if
change of scenery can help at alberto
montecito there you go good located
fastball right at the top of the zone
fourth strikeout for bieber third inning
in kansas city no score
bieber's two strike pitch and strike
three called fastball in the outside
corner mary field is victim number five
for bieber that is his 80th strikeout
on the 3-2
blew it by him upstairs really good
work
by shane bieber to get through the third
inning he struck out a half dozen royals
and he hits it well into left center
field alex got a good break and runs to
the gap to take a hit away from lindor
three and two-thirds scoreless and he
has a strikeout per inning in his career
against cleveland and he's got another
strikeout tonight he has three in four
scoreless innings after seven starts
with 75 strikeouts he had 65 through six
starts there's a pitch that's on the
outside corner at the belt call strike
three he'll get naquin luplow and perez
in the fifth inning
good pitch there he jammed tyler naquin
and that's the second time he has
grounded out to nikki lopez
hard hit again to franco
and so it goes when you're having a bad
year even when you hit it hard there's
somebody standing right there
and there are two outs
here's pitch number 82 with two down in
the fifth inning
and talking about ground balls right on
cue three up three down on three ground
balls
and keller needed only seven pitches
does roberto call for a high fastball
here no yeah well it was a good fastball
just punched him out he just blew it
right by him
i mean this was just gas
here's the pitch to gallagher fastball
called strike three on the outside
corner
number nine for shane bieber
that's putting him up putting him down
keller strikes out his fourth it's just
because
it just breaks so late you don't see it
there it was right on his hands
three up three down that's a 12 pitch
sixth inning
drilled
and there's a base hit for santana and a
rare hit this year
when he's been down on the count here's
from reyes as lined out and struck out
he and jose ramirez share the team lead
and homers with seven
drilled in the gap lindor
gotta go santana excuse me is off and
running he's on his way to third they're
gonna wave him home
and no throw to the plate the indians
will take the lead as front meal reyes
delivers a one out rbi double up the
alley in left center field
one nothing cleveland reyes with his
24th run batted in on the year phil may
todd is the new indians pitcher he takes
over for shane bieber
a little soft liner and that's going to
be down in right field so the royals
have their lead off man on for just the
second make that third time tonight
and that's just their second hit
they used to
what what made me so
that hit him okay he did i just clipped
him that'll get him in scoring position
and then you know we're at the bottom of
the order here where the royals have not
had a lot of production
one-nothing cleveland leading it royals
have two on two out in the seventh wit
merrifield the batter nick witgren on
for the 15th time this year
drilled the left
back goes luplow makes the catch and
hangs on
and that ends the inning and look at the
frustration of whitmerfield he hit that
ball right on the barrel and luplow
almost got turned around but he hung
with it and made the play
and solaire
lays off the 3-2 pitch and the royals
have back-to-back walks
to begin the eighth inning and now
franco
and franco lines it into left field
that's going to tie the game as dozier
comes to the plate
so michael franco
has had two big plate appearances
against
karen check this year
and the game is tied at one in the
eighth adam simmer on for the tenth time
this year oh line center field base hit
here's solaire here's the shield's throw
and it's cut off immediately
that ball was cut off before it even got
to the infield dirt and bubba starling
down in the count comes through and the
royals lead 2-1 now howling has reduced
the game down to one out
and it's a ground ball to the right side
nikki lopez is there and the royals with
two runs in the bottom of the eighth
inning the only runs they scored all
night take game one from the indians
tonight 2-1